my full name is haftan kiddo aragai
i'm 25 years old i came from
chigrai town homura
i was happy when i was there with my
family and i was helping my family
i was playing with my friends i was
playing with my brothers even my mother
says my sister you know
when you are far away from your family
you know
you maybe you become unhappy
you sad you know i pray to the god
to save my family when i go to the
church
i pray to god please save my family like
this one
i feel sad when i think the future of
this old people is why because
there are so many people they lose their
family like fathers like mothers like
sister brothers
i mean there are some people
there was on good life like civil
cervantes
they have salary payments they can make
their lives good but
these were it becomes bring to the
bad life the sake of this one especially
the sake of this one
so many people they go to the refuge you
know
they become hopeless i have stayed 10
days but when i look when i observe i
have observed this old campus
there is not good food you know still
now some of them they sleep on the
ground
some of them they sleep on the plastic
shield
even you know this is not good
still now 2020 40 grey people this is
badur you know
all the i write down in my family in my
life
bad year you know for the future the
tiguay people is become poor
you will be died on the drought why
because there is not any sargon
by the way the condition or the season
was
harvesting season if you look the sargon
if you look the system not harvested
you know if the you know the great
people eight percent they live on the
agriculture by harvesting like
uh sargon like they like system you know
if they cannot harvest it how they can
live already i don't want to go back
there
why because if there is not freedom if
there is not peace
i cannot go there if there is freedom
wherever that's my country